bien effectivement nous sommes venus
chez hubert de givenchy et puisqu'aussi
bien ce numéro est consacré à
l'autocritique et pour ma part je ne
vois pas pourquoi on n'aurait pas dans
le cas d'un couturier d'autocritique
j'aimerais que ce soit néanmoins simone
baron qui vous posent mais ce dimanche
et quelques questions cherub r comment
êtes vous arrivé à faire une collection
si merveilleusement gêne je crois simone
c'est un ensemble
un ensemble par la ligne la forme
les coloris car il ya beaucoup de
couleurs dans la collection d'hiver j'ai
pensé qu'après l'été si affreux que nous
avons vu cette saison nous pouvions
faire une collection au contraire avec
beaucoup de couleurs très très vive très
gai très jeune voilà dans les lainages
dans dans les lainages dans l'est soit
surtout donné les nages mais vous voyez
là un très gros risque parce que c'est
l'hiver malheureusement et moselle ça
c'était triste mais c'est vraiment bon
mais puisque vous parliez de couleurs il
ya un instant et je regrette précisément
que la télévision soit encore couleurs
mais est-ce qu'on ne voyait pas en noir
et blanc nous dessiner quelque chose à
illustrer la manière dont vous pensez un
modèle où je boite c'est intéressant de
même de voir enfin cette création naître
sous nos yeux
consciemment très ralentie
voilà c'est la ligne avec cette pointe
c'est très joli on dirait un peu un
corsage corset vous allez enlever la
tache rouge la taille et ça parle ça
fait quand même ça prend la forme d'un
empiècement 12 repartent les france et
c'est vous les épaules nues complètement
ça prend les épaules ça les a en boîte
saleh et la juge lui est arrivé à
combien du sol la jupe est environ à
38,10 seuls 38 38 centimes si ce n'est
pas une robe l'après midi sinon c'est
une robe de cocktail une robe de petits
soir noire cette facile elle est noire
et de la bande qui est ici est en noir
noir êtes contente de l'hexagone la wii
parce qu'il sait que nous n'aurons pas
par la couleur et toutes les lectrices
aime bien y avoir et que vous vous aurez
de la couleur numéro car nous avons la
couleur très brillante j'espère et alors
quelle est la couleur est ce qu'il ya
une couleur qui domine il y avait
globalement beaucoup de couleurs qui
domine et il ya des maïs il y avait
beaucoup de bleu des bleus
j'ai appelé bleus sublime c'est un bleu
papa turquoise un bleu un bleu assez
clair tout en étant profond c'est très
compliqué à expliquer et il ya les
jaunes il y à des grilles et tout ça
dans des coloris très frais d'écolage
beaucoup pesé
oui bon est ce que nous pourrions
maintenant parce que je vois que ce
croquis est terminée et est ce que nous
pourrions voir l'illustration d'un
nouveau parce que j'en ferai une mode un
nouveau truc sur un mannequin nous
fernand bar là un détail comment le
concevez vous comment se fait il ne
songe pas au sérieux malgré une à la
collection évidemment et sa très
volontiers wii music man mais alors si
vous voulez
faites nous voir comment vous avez fait
cette forme et des grands succès c'est
marrant que le fils succès
pas toujours facile voire aussi voilà
elle est partie de ces pointes de moire
et pourrait fortement
d'où le départ est pas dit s'ils
repartent en tirant toutes les france
comme un jaillissement est-ce qu'on
pourrait par aussi aux simples messieurs
vous est simple mais on retrouve
logiquement dépassés
là-bas le premier costume voilà le
premier costume
c'est un ensemble du matin vous voyez là
bas ce qui est très court et ça frôle à
peine les hanches la modestie est en
outre noir ça vous aimez ça j'aime ça
j'aime je suis d'accord avec vous ça
c'est encore dans la même idée c'est
l'ensemble dans un shetland violet est
toujours dans la même idée avec la
basque très courte qui font les hanches
sans que ça plus d'âme n'est pas tout à
fait du coach et grands cols drapée aux
lectrices
j'ai mieux l'autre grand succès c'est
une vesse de ce lot pour la première
fois mélangés avec l'hermine des boutons
sont en perles sastre est amusant vous
avez une très jolie photo dans féminin
un nouveau féminin c'est encore un
ensemble du matin en velours côtelé
notre jeu dit on chez les femmes aiment
beaucoup leur côté oui quand je te jette
une jolie et matière dans le fond ça
peut être aussi bien habillé une pagaie
trouve beaucoup mais ça c'est la robe du
soir est celle que vous n'aimez pas vous
aimez moi j'aime moins j'aime moins
surtout parce qu'à l'aide d'un prix
extrêmement élevé les batteries c'est ça
c'est moi aussi ça vous l'avez oui
voilà simone je vous ai montré les rssi
vers le 5 robes vous avez professionne
presque d'accord pas tout à fait
[Musique]